wir haben einiges zu besprechen meine
lieben und das erste thema ist natürlich
der lock down in gütersloh gütersloh im
ausnahmezustand 7000 mitarbeiter der
firma tönnies in quarantäne
640.000 menschen wieder in corona
lockdown wir führen wieder eine kontakt
beschränkung auf den familien und
haushalts verbund ein wie im märz wegen
tennis österreich verhängt
reisewarnungen für nrw urlaub für
gütersloher nur mit kleiner test schulen
geschlossen bars und kinos sichtkontakt
beschränkungen muss das unternehmen
jetzt für schäden haften droht die
zweite corona welle ja 640.000 menschen
sind jetzt vom erneuten lockdown
betroffen
die frage geht jetzt direkt an sie von
mir und ich frag mich so ein bisschen
also erstmal muss ich grundsätzlich
sagen dass ich es sehr schade findet
dass erst eine zweite corona welle
kommen muss bevor man ein bisschen
darüber nachdenkt was schon seit jahren
in der kritik steht nämlich die
werksverträge jetzt meine frage warum
dauert das so lange war warum hat man
das jetzt nicht behoben in der
zwischenzeit das ist ja jetzt nicht so
dass wir das erst seit gestern müssen
weil ich nicht also das ist wirklich
schon ein thema was uns ganz lange
verfolgt und es sind auch immer wieder
schritte unternommen worden
leider konnte sich aber nicht immer
sozusagen die parteien die grad regiert
haben dann einigen das hängt ja oft
dinge aber was man sagen muss wir haben
ja immer wieder erkannt wir müssen hier
leute schützen also beispielsweise die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer die da
kommen
es gibt eine ich hab noch selber
einrichten können eine
ungleichbehandlung stelle wo man
beispielsweise dann hingehen kann und
sagen kann ich bekomme mein geld nicht
die unterkunft ist ganz anders als es
mir gesagt wurde
man tut so als hätte ich nur weniger
gearbeitet also zehn stunden statt 20
stunden und so aber es ist schwierig
weil die menschen sind auch oft wirklich
tief getroffen
durch das was sie an finden gibt
sicherlich einige die das so an und
kommt und einfach geld verdienen wollen
aber ganz viele habe ich erlebt in
meiner zeit die wirklich tief getroffen
waren und die dann gar nicht erst sagen
jetzt gehe ich in so ein verfahren so
ein langwieriges an das muss ich dann
von zu hause noch führen und so
und lassen ist und dadurch kommen
natürlich schon auch diejenigen die
leute so ausnutzen ungeschoren davon und
dass es eben nicht in ordnung jetzt will
die bundesregierung das ja ändern bis
zum nächsten jahr sollen diese
werksverträge leiharbeitsverträgen
abgeschafft werden
und jetzt soll endlich dafür gesorgt
werden dass einfach für ihre bedingungen
sind und man auch im verantwortlichen
hat der dann dafür haften aber meinen
sie das wird auch wirklich tatsächlich
passieren oder ist das wieder ein loch
ich glaube corona sei dank muss man ja
fast schon etwas merkt wagen ist jetzt
ein druck dahinter und es betrifft ja
plötzlich alle es betrifft ja nicht nur
in anführungsstrichen das werk sondern
eben alle drum herum die sind jetzt alle
davon betroffen dass sie es heißt auf
einmal ihr dürft nicht zu unseren reisen
ihr dürft nicht bei uns urlaub machen
wir wollen die leute nicht aus der
region
da sind ja alle plötzlich angesprochen
und finde es auch nicht in ordnung der
druck ist da und ich glaub ich bin doch
recht sicher also man muss ja mal
vorsichtig sein als politikerin aber ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher das schaffen wir
bis anfang nächsten jahres
es ist ja auch klar dass es mit der
abschaffung der werksverträge jetzt
nicht getan ist also offenbar hat man ja
viel zu lange die augen verschlossen die
gesamte politik die augen verschlossen
vor einem thema über das alle bescheid
wussten und zum anderen stellt sich
jetzt ganz genau dass offenbar wenn man
in der fleischindustrie geld verdienen
möchte oder reich werden möchte muss man
ein schwein sein
sprich man muss einfach schauen wo sind
die grauzonen wie kann ich sie umgehen
und m kontrollen werden offenbar nicht
genug durchgeführt und das ist ja mit
den mit der abschaffung mehr
werkverträge oder auch wie alle sagen
mit einem teureren fleisch gar nicht
getan es ist ja offenbar bisher ganz
grundsätzlich so gearbeitet wird um ganz
billig und schnell zu produzieren und
dann ist es dem verbraucher ja aber
dafür musste teureres fleisch kaufen
damit du diese dieses verpassen dieses
verschlafen von einem beteiligten wieder
ausmerzen kannst und das ist ein punkt
der regt nicht wahnsinnig aber es heißt
du schiebst durch die schuld schon
richtung tunis die politik hat
geschlagen
jens weiß ganz genau was er was er tut
und auch auf landesebene es muss eben
auch kontrolliert werden was dort falls
ja aber also zu viele grauzonen gibt
wenn ich da mal einmal nur das den
regnen darf also heute gab es ja zum
beispiel auch wieder so eine umfrage
jetzt weiß man dass alles was in dem
werk vor sich geht und essen sie das
fleisch oder nicht und die leute es
eben doch oder aber auch die frage
natürlich wollen sie dass sich etwas
ändert wenn das fleisch dadurch teurer
wird und da gibt's nicht ganz so dieses
schwarz weiß weil ich ein steak für 13
euro oder so kann sich eben nicht jeder
leisten und als sozialdemokrat in sag
ich mal finde ich das auch nicht in
ordnung aber wir brauchen daneben mehr
subventionen für die bauern die weniger
fleisch natürlich produzieren können
aber die kühe oder die tiere halt etwas
besser halten
nur wo bekommen wir dann das ganze
fleisch her für alle es ist nicht ganz
so leicht es ist aber auch in zwölf
punkte plan muss man sagen wir können
jetzt hier nicht alle zwölf punkte
besprechen
aber es geht eben zum einen natürlich
darum wie es den arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmern geht aber auch darum was
uns natürlich stärker schützt als
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher nur da
wird noch viel mehr kommen müssen nur
wir müssen alle mitmachen also wir
dürfen nicht sagen auch am ende dann
doch für einen euro ist ja irgendwie
besser hätte das nicht so viel kosten
wie schachteln zigaretten das ist klar
aber ich finde man muss auch so eine
balance finden wie sie ja auch alle
seiten zwischen ich beispielsweise ich
habe drei kinder ich kann es mir nicht
leisten für alle beteiligten einer
familie immer das beste bio zeugs unter
schacht die sind ja das würde ich sehr
gerne aber ich kann es wenig weiß man
ich glaube es geht sehr vielen menschen
ich glaube es gibt menschen auch noch
viel schlechter also gerade wenn das
arbeitnehmer denken an die riegen die
auf diese wächst verträge angewiesen
waren für die es keine lohnfortzahlung
gab wir müssen hier von menschenwürde
reden das hat mir letzte woche gemacht
müssen wir wieder wiederholen
und es ist glaube ich auch die spitze
vom eisberg das was wir gerade sehen
es geht allen fleisch betrieben so
bundesweit in deutschland das ist das
besorgniserregende dass sich sozusagen
dieser bereich und sektor zum
billiglohnsektor entwickelt hat dass es
deutsche gibt die diese jobs nicht
machen wollen
und anstelle dessen kommen dann
sozusagen auch die arbeitnehmer aus
bulgarien aus rumänien
und das ist natürlich auch in so eine
sehr aufgeheizte stimmung dann trifft
und die tatsache sage ich mal das tennis
der einer der erfolgreichsten
fleischereien in ganz europa ist
bedeutet für mich im umkehrschluss aber
nicht dass es da sonderrechte gibt und
ich glaube das ist so ein problem hin
dass das so ein bisschen da sich gerade
gerade was sozusagen auch die listen ein
versteck gerade was die listen angeht
zum beispiel die gesundheitsämter ja
nicht aus richtung anrecht auf bezug zu
bekommen auf diese listen was heißt dass
auf der anderen seite für den taxifahrer
dreht seinen job nicht nachgehen kann
wenn gütersloh wieder im lot steht das
hat ja sozusagen
auch auswirkungen konsequenzen ein tier
muss natürlich komplett aufgeklärt
werden so zu sagen und das ist glaube
ich ganz entscheidend dass wir da auch
sozusagen durch corona bedingt jetzt
ganz genau hingucken und uns da gerade
auch als endverbraucher nichts vormachen
dürfen und natürlich entscheidet der in
verbraucher am ende auch wie teuer das
fleisch ist und das muss uns zu denken
geben wenn das gleich so günstig ist
dass wir uns eben überlegen da werden
auch menschen sozusagen für benutzt und
ich denke schon dass das bewusstsein
dafür auch vernünftig ist und dass man
das etablieren kann
und es war ja früher auch so gerade bei
arbeitnehmern dass man dann eben weniger
fleisch gegessen hat das kann man jetzt
nicht verlangen ist klar aber
nichtsdestotrotz sage ich haben sich die
verhältnisse doch verändert und ich
finde für jeden und ich esse auch gerne
fleisch aber ich habe selber mal in
fleischer betrieb sozusagen auch
gedrehten paar tage also das muss man
sich dann auch mal angucken wie das
vonstatten geht und das was wir in den
kantinen gesehen haben war das gegenteil
und wie kann es sein dass wir in der
gaststätte überall so die
unterschriftenlisten ausfüllen müssen
und dass das sozusagen für eine
fleischerei beispielsweise dann nicht
gilt weil er nämlich angegeben und den
kantinen alle zusammen also hier aber
ich war das gemälde das mäßigkeit ist
sozusagen verstehe ich total was du
sagst und ich finde auch natürlich er
wird jetzt enorm an den pranger gestellt
er hat ja auch mist gebaut dann müssen
uns alle nichts vorlag
er ist erstens ist endlich der einzige
wer weiß was da noch alles auf uns
zukommt irgendwelche berichte und unter
das ist ja genau das problem finde ich
das eigentlich müssen wir noch einen
schritt noch weiter zurückgehen sagen ja
er hat mist gebaut aber er durfte es ja
sogar es gab ja kein gesetz was ihm das
verboten hat das sind dass damit möchte
ich nicht sagen dass es ok war versteht
mich bitte nicht falsch aber irgendwie
müssen wir doch passiert also hat ihm
gesagt halt so ein bisschen der muss
schon wissen eigentlich wäre für ihn
arbeitet nur so davon geht man ja aus
und dass die das dann die ganze zeit
nicht genau sagen können und nicht
wissen und so ist natürlich nicht
richtig aber das ist ja durch diese
bedingungen gefördert worden dass es
dann subunternehmer subunternehmen auch
unternehmer gibt und bis sich das alles
dann durchgesetzt hat ich möchte aber
auch schon noch mal eine lanze für diese
menschen brechen die da sind ich habe
leute kennengelernt im schiffsbau
beispielsweise um mal vielleicht ein
ganz anderes beispiel zu nehmen
die waren richtig gut in arbeit in
bulgarien zwar keine armen menschen die
jetzt unbedingt irgendwo was suchen
damit der wirt hingegangen
wir haben was tolles für euch kommt nach
deutschland super bedingungen super job
und dann sitzen sie hier bekommen ihren
lohn nicht dann heißt es immer achten
monat noch warten und dann oder noch im
monat oder jetzt habe ich nur die hälfte
und die sind richtig tief enttäuscht
weil sie sich von deutschland was
anderes erwartet haben und dafür
eigentlich recht jung aber wenn wir das
denn auch wirklich konkret auf die frage
an die politik denn wir dies ändert auch
gerade richtig gesagt wir finden kaum
jemanden der diesen job machen will das
ist ein knochenjob man steht stundenlang
und teils schweine hände immer dieselbe
bewegung in der kälte sowie helfen wir
jetzt nur wenn ich mich in einen
fleischfabrikanten ist rein versetzte
wie soll wie ist es möglich also wie
bienen finden wir da wenn man jetzt sagt
ich zahle die mehr geld meinen sie wie
finden dann jemanden aus deutschland der
sagt kommt dann mache ich das überzeugt
doch das glaube ich schon
also natürlich geht es eben damit einher
was unterstütze ich an welcher stelle
das ist ja immer so und ich kann also
ich bin schon ein fan von biobauern so
aber dass das kann wird nicht sozusagen
für alle reichen das ist ja schon mal
das eine das heißt ich muss jetzt in
diesen mittelweg kommen
auf der einen seite zu erwarten dass die
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer wissen
wer bei ihnen arbeitet wer da alles ist
dass die bedingungen stimmen dass sie
vier sind dass sie nicht alle auf einem
haufen und vor allen dingen nicht die
sind ja nicht acht stunden in diesen
wenigen grad kälte da wo sie stehen
sondern oft noch viel länger was uns
immer alle speziell sind wir sind aber
und das dafür muss derjenige direkt
zuständig sein also ich muss den
ansprechpartner haben mit dem ich das
aus handel und das ist doch das
normalste was wir in deutschland jemand
handeln es muss vieles neu sortiert
werden und neu überlegen
[Musik]